all right what the [__] natto come on
Nat is I mean it is the superfood that I
could
eat look at me okay I I'll accept Nat
but like you can't look at me and tell
me that Nat top nine foods of all time
better than American barbecue better
than pizza better than uh no way better
than
Indian we're talking about breakfast
foods that's the king of breakfast foods
right there
bro you're delusional on a bed of rice
also Nat can be used in all sorts of
different dude Nat and Curry is Bon okay
okay you're delusional amazing Nat in a
sushi form amazing explain to me this
okay explain to me this all right I've
had Nat we've all had Nat I'm fine with
the flavor of Nat and everything I mean
he's not but yeah he's not all right all
right but food texture is important
right bad texture TT texture is
important right texture is import sell
me on a food that has the same texture
profile as Flem just like just like just
is just just explain how you mentally
not only does it does it have the
texture of flam it also looks like flam
look at that
picture like a I'm going to say it I
don't give a [__] about the texture of
food that's crazy to me that's CRA I
literally do not care about the texture
of you just backing me up on the
snap I'll eat baby food if I have to I
don't give a [__] as long as it tastes
good I don't care texture so also to me
here's the other thing as well also to
me it's kind of we're not even standing
at the same starting line because this
is a texture to me that's not weird
because I've had it all my goddamn life
right so obviously you guys are going to
think texture is important because there
are some textures out there in food
Cuisines which are just out of the norm
for you guys to me Nat is a very normal
texture to me but you you're also
arguing that texture isn't important no
it's not something I'm going to be like
uh this disgusting like I've had so I've
literally had all sorts of different
like you know sticky you know slimy
whatever [__] growing up that to me that
texture is normal texture is massively
important texture like texture sometimes
you you get I can't believe this's
that's just a weak mindset if you ask me
I can't believe that this is top
sometimes it is as important as the
taste I was like trying trying to like
weak mindset it's it's okay okay have
you ever had for example soggy Fried
Chicken you know fried chicken that's
been out too long and it just doesn't
have that same like crispiness to it it
tastes the same but you heat up in the
microwave [__] tastes awful like I'll
e it it just like it's just well I've
been a broke college student before I'm
not going to pick and choose this [__]
even as I get that but I would never
have Fried Chicken like I'll never have
it over the [__] fresh [__] obviously
yeah but what I'm saying is is that like
this whole idea of the the sticky flamy
texture being like you know the end all
be all of everything in terms of food I
think is just a weak mindset I think I
have a weak mindset there enough to
discourage me uh fair enough uh
watermelon um best fruit arguably well I
I hate disagreeing with everything but
yeah I disagree I disagree uh it's the
it's it's the best fruit because you get
the most out of your bank for buck like
you get a giant [__] watermelon you
get so much out of that it is it is
watery so you know you can hydrate
yourself at the same time right melon is
just better in every way melon sometimes
has just too much flavor what the melons
also melon can get some sometimes melon
can get a bit
soggy and watermelon can't
no watermelon is like it is I think what
is the makeup of watermelon it's like 99
like something [__] water yeah that's
what's what good it's it's basically
like it's like when you you know when
you have like uh the the drinks where
you like concentrate and you add water
it's like that if you like someone spat
some of the concentrate into a glass and
then you put two lers of water you're
like I have it the fresh watermelon
juice 92% 92% the fresh watermelon juice
I had in Thailand like confirmed to me
that watermelon is the best I would say
the watermelon is definitely top tier
it's a top tier for I disag 100% in the
summer as
well watermelon it's better than banana
it's way better ban it is way better
than banana kidding me not even in the
same Le [__] are we talking about here
let's be let's be reasonable adults here
come on banana banana overrated are you
kidding me I'm not kidding you like
banana it's like I don't dislike banana
like you know I don't have like a heavy
dislike for banana it's it's good I I I
enjoy it it's it's I'll eat it yeah what
the [__] are you guys talking about I'll
eat it but not it's not my first nor
fifth choice you guys are delusional the
Banana's kind of like the my here
Academia fruit what the I won't stand up
I Wen stand for that comment you you
need to take that comment back op my
hero Academia is like the monster of you
are insulting my entire being right now
you cannot say that it's just like safe
it has this like good point okay huh
everybody likes it it's good for any
occasion but is it the best out there no
no watermelon certainly is not banana
Leaps and Bounds ahead of the watermelon
it actually has flavor it doesn't
crumble into water in your mouth after
one bite that's what I love about it why
why you got to have [__] seeds in
there bro what an annoying [__] seeds
get the seedless ones yeah watermelons
yeah watermelon is more like you know a
tack on Titan you know it's like yeah
[__] bloated and goes on for too long
you know you know compared to like some
you know it's still very very popular
but you don't see it around as often as
like you know the mainstream kind of
fruits like [__] bananas app
watermelon watermelon be laying low in
the winter but when the summer oh my God
it is the star of the show the beta
seasonal fruit versus the Chad all
[Applause]
rounder perfect portion ready for any
occasion always the right amount of
f more nutritional value it's better in
every single way like the thing the
thing looks a [__] you know you know
like it's not just the fruit it's not
just the fruit but you know if you have
like messy you you know if you have like
a watermelon like sweet you know it's
going to [__] s watermelon flavored
things trumps banana flavored things any
day ofek any day of the week any day of
the [__] week go back to your natto
Strawberry Shortcake bollocks [__] off I
don't it's delicious I want to stand for
this the only thing that keeps
watermelon from being like the perfect
fruit is the seeds that's like that's
like the only thing and and the lack of
flavor I I was okay there's there's two
things it's just like there are
different like tears it's like you it's
like you have like the sweet Center
which is like [__] Godlike and then
you get close to like the crust and it
starts to become a little more like
flavorless as you get closer to the edge
and you just have to like take that L
only only in the watermelon uh context
that I will be a crossers gang with with
G uh you know when whenever I have
watermelon whenever I buy like a big
watermelon during the summer I don't
even do like the [__] triangular [__]
like that like I cut it up into blocks
so that I can just get rid of all the
crust immediately and I can I'm just
left with the good [__] yeah not every
bite of watermelon is the same when it
comes to like especially you get close
to the edge it gets a bit little tougher
a little uh let's dude you put that [__]
in the freezer let it sit for a little
bit on a really hot summer day and you
crack that [__] open godamn but bu what
can I say watermelon still a top tier
fruit top fruit best fruit I would agree
with you Joy banana not all all right me
so sh very safe very safe op yeah this
is comfort food for me I mean you know
growing up in a Japanese household this
is like a type of thing which is super
easy to make uh you know very versatile
you can put anything inside miso soup
and most of the time it works very very
well you know this one has leak and uh
tofu in it but like you know you can put
uh carrot steak on onion um seaweed you
know anything goes like there's there's
a ton of different things you can put it
in it and white or red miso ooh see when
I was growing up in sandai we had white
miso yeah uh but I do like red miso as
well I like Mis more red miso is good
more intensity more flavor yeah I agree
with that but it is a good comfort food
I I'll let you have that one yeah and
also great for hangovers best thing to
have for hangovers great in general just
great in general you want to warm up if
you're sick you're hung over you just
want something you know to fill yourself
up for a little bit Mis I just can't
think of a situation where I wouldn't
think it's acceptable yeah like I I I
honestly think miso soup has that power
where it just like transcends Cuisines I
would you know I would love to have miso
soup in like any kind of Cuisine you
know I'm trying to think I'm trying to
think of a starter like a Cuisine where
it wouldn't work as a starter and would
yeah yeah I think kind of works with
everything uh you have suaki suaki yeah
that's my favorite Hot Pot again
memories of you know me and the family
eating it once a year it is the best hot
pot of all the Japanese it is the best
hot pot give me give me Chinese hot pot
Chinese hot pot to me is is is superior
I I was this close to putting Chinese
hot on my 3x3 actually I like Chinese
hot pot butak I like suyaki Mo I think
yeah there's a different level of shaki
is too clean there's a different level
of comfort and balance yeah to n Chinese
hotot has like has all of those [__]
herbs and the flavor and it's just so
strong and the [__] meat just soaks
up like the the Sukiyaki soup is just
too it's it's not flavorful enough you
know cuz one one part I love about like
the hot pots is just putting a bunch of
[__] in it and having whatever
ingredients you put in it just soak up
that flavor and to me Chinese hot pots
because the soup is way like to me like
thicker um and more flavorful it just
you can taste it so much more in the
ingredients you put in m and Sukiyaki
yeah it's a little bit cleaner
definitely you you come out of it not
hating your body yeah which is I guess
like big thing but to me given the
choice okay do I want to be health
conscious or I want to eat something
that [__] slaps Andro I don't shyak
is healthy at all is it not healthy at
all no that mean it's a lot of soy sauce
load of soy so it's very very salty uh I
mean the ingredient more healthier in
comparison yeah the ingredients you
throw in are definitely more healthier
than otherwise but I wouldn't
necessarily say Chinese has like way
more oils in it uh oh yeah yeah so yeah
yeah I mean like this is one thing where
like I'll always have a craving for it
like this is one of those things where
like I love it it's one of my favorite
Japanese foods but it's one of those
Japanese Foods where like I only want to
eat it maybe like 2 or three times a
year and nothing more cuz like if I have
it more often than that I feel the magic
of it is going to disappear and I'm very
happy with it being like a thing where
it's just happens you know once every
happen stance and when that happen
stance happens you're just like hell
yeah I I [__] deserve this this is
goated especially this time of year it's
yucky goated uh the last one is chicken
puos so this is my favorite Hungarian
food looks uh that my again my favorite
thing that my grandma used to make uh
it's basically uh chicken thigh and
chicken wing uh in a paprika sauce with
uh this thing called nedly uh which is
kind of like I don't know how to explain
yly it's kind of like uh halfway between
pasta and bread okay it's the only way
to describe hon it looks [__]
incredible it is so good it is really
really really good and I really want to
learn how to make this um but yeah this
is another one where like like if I
would go to Every time I would go to my
Grandma's place she'd either make me
spaghetti bnes or chicken poyh and those
are the only two things I ever asked
half the time she's [__] doing your
dirty like I be I come on hey man
chicken property because takes a long
time there's no shot I'm taking the
spaghetti over there are you kidding me
what the [__] yeah like I I was craving
this so much during uh the pandemic
obviously cuz I couldn't go see my
grandma that uh I was looking up like
Hungarian restaurants in Tokyo I found
one one Hungarian restaurant to and they
had chicken poosh it was good but I was
like damn like Grandma magic is a real
thing oh yeah yeah and it's just not the
same I don't know I don't know what the
difference was but it just didn't taste
the same have you ever tried learning
the dish my sister's learned how to make
it and she's gotten better at it uh I
this is like one thing I mean I don't
really care about she she doesn't have
the grandma buff she you just grandma
she okay so like my grandma actually
wrote the recipe for this but the way
she wrote it was the most eastern Old
Eastern European woman way of writing
look to the East and grab the spice you
seek no no she said like get the paprika
at a good amount and I'm like what
what's a good amount you know it's fire
it's like you know it's the good amount
yeah but like that's the thing about
ingredients like like recipes like this
cuz I've had similar instances with my
mom where I've craved some of her
cooking and she's tried to like walk me
through step by step somehow I [__] it
up somewhere
I I like I don't know how this is
possible cuz I've literally had her on a
zoom call I'm like Mom how' you how' you
make your Curry and she's like all right
let me walk you through step by step
taste different and doesn't like somehow
where she's like I I don't even know if
she knows how much she puts in she just
like it's it's like Ultra Instinct you
know it's like she knows the right
amount of ingredients and when I start
measuring [__] that's how I know it's
not going to be as good toally yeah okay
yeah so that's mine 3x3 some I agree
with some I don't agree with fair enough
I feel that's going to be the case with
all of our 3x middle row I don't agree
no [__] you watermelon is the best dog
watermelon is the best I don't know